I hope they learned about me that I'm a  fighter and I'll never give up and I  hope they learned from me that I mean  anything is possible if you work hard  and just continue the dream day I mean  like I said if somebody told me this  maybe three weeks ago I probably  wouldn't believe it but I think just  putting in the work definitely raised my  confidence because I knew how hard I  worked and I knew what shots I could  make and what was possible so and I'm  only 15 and this is like I've not nearly  we've gotten developed my game like I  mean I started tennis at six so I'm I  have I'm so excited to see if I continue  to work hard to see what other success I  can do in the future